time for the
fastest all right a new survey says 48%
of people have gone to a holiday party
just for the
treats among the top flavors of this
time of year gingerbread salted caramel
and peppermint and speaking of treats we
have a holiday spread here peppermint
stick chocolate swirl cheesecake from
the Cheesecake Factory you know that's
not really a factory I found that out
when I went on the tour and candy cane
chill Blizzard from Dairy Queen which is
our
royalty yeah no Harold um I don't
understand how they make choices uh when
it comes to Holiday sweets for example
no one likes Fruit Chews right no one
bites into those chocolates and they
just leave them there why do they why do
they persist in including such terrible
sweets well in the Christmas spirit I I
think it's important to not that some
people people may like those things and
they are part of the decorative kind of
thing we look we look for on Christmas
morning at least some many of us do I
don't like sweets I'm really a bad I
don't eat sweets I like sweets I don't
eat sweets but I do like the decorative
kind of aesthetic of it all of course
you do decorative athetic you know
Harold you taught me that Jesse um
taught you a
lot I you know I enjoy sweets but
couldn't you argue this is a war on
diabetics when I saw this survey I
thought man these people are overweight
and when I mean these people I mean the
American people who goes to a holiday
party just for the food the
judge okay well that explains it I don't
know I think we just need discipline you
don't have to have the whole piece you
can just have a few bites Greg and
that's just a good life lesson in
general it really is moderation
moderation even in moderation yes who
said that I don't know Ben Franklin
no he was
quite some of these uh are you a pumpkin
spice person I find that to be
completely overrated me yeah I like
everything sweet everything spicy I love
peanut brittle at Christmas time I'll
find where the kids are and raid their
stockings I like remember the popcorn
balls when we were kids they don't make
them like that anymore they were they
were hard and glued together probably
with glue uh and we ate them so I love
that and remember the ribbon candy oh
God oh no I remember they stick together
your grandparents would have them in a
dish usually an ashtray yeah no but they
would stick together by the first of the
year if you ate them on Christmas day
like you should you know Dana one thing
you know that I've never had eggnog in
my
life really yeah it just looks like
pancake batter to me why would you H
it's disgusting first of all since Carol
forgot it's good to be back around the
table yes yes yes merry christmasm day
eggn yeah my parents used to have like
it used to come in a carton yeah you
have and I would take a swig of that but
I didn't know you were supposed to put
alcohol in it I never had it like with
the alcohol um I think that this
blizzard is actually pretty good you're
you can't overindulge I'll tell you the
best Christmas treat I had this season
though um hemmer has an
assistant and Caroline my assistant they
made Christmas cookies for the American
mus room holiday party those were good
the cookies were excellent so I indulged
a little bit that was my lunch one day
did you give me some of those yeah yeah
a anyway I can say that because I don't
care up next it's the season of giving
but not everyone is into that idea the
new poll finds that 60% of holiday
Shoppers will be buying gifts for
themselves and not
necessarily others you know Jesse this
seems like something you would do I
participated in the survey I remember
when they called me and I said I have 20
minutes to talk to the telemarket this
is what we're going to use on the five I
don't see anything wrong with going
shopping for other people and getting
yourself something MH but if you're just
going shopping for other people and then
you forget about the other people and
just get yourself something that's not
right you know what I like to do Dana
when I will go shop I will buy somebody
like a food gift basket but I'll take
some stuff out of it for me is that
wrong what you take out or I'll take
this the best stuff cuz they'll never
know and sometimes there'll be things in
my pantry that I haven't eaten I'll put
them into the gift basket like a like a
tin of baked beans exact they go oh wow
those are classic baked beans that's
right those are organic baked beans and
you put those on toast and then you make
it like a British thing exactly briti GI
basket no I I do are is anybody else at
the stage now where where you you were
getting things that you forgot that you
ordered mhm like oh this was supposed to
be for her but I guess I'll have to keep
it that I ended up with a lot of that
stuff to yeah you know what I'm giving
judge all of the covid tests I'm getting
in the m i just are you putting him in
the food basket putting him in the food
basket covid test yeah CU I care I care
D you know what they should do a covid k
gift basket with masks and like little V
give it to my mother yeah and a and a
k95 and all that good stuff and then um
what aren't you supposed to eat when you
have Co did they ever say we shouldn't
eat anything no no I think so right well
you didn't have nobody had a sense of
taste so yeah so that's where the big
beans are for yeah
smell Harold we're trying to keep it
clean this Christmas after all you can
leave your fart humor for whatever you
do after these shows it's really
disgusting um do you do a lot of
shopping on I don't see you shopping
Harold I see you having people shop for
you I do a lot of shopping but first of
all it's Christmas uh there should be a
lot of joy and love around around the
table
forgiveness yeah this this is the I tell
people all the time I get asked all the
time what it's like to be with everybody
around this table every day and it's a
joy and Merry Christmas and it's been a
great year and we'll have it even better
next year I love shopping for other
people uh matter fact I don't go shoping
the judge I talked about this I don't I
have not bought a gift for myself in
years I'll go go out and I love going in
the stores MH uh I I love people walk up
to me said do you know Jesse Waters uh
you know J jeene Janine do you know you
know Greg do you know Dana which happens
often and um when you I have two little
kids I love buying from my kids I love
going in kids stores and toy stores I'm
not allowed in kid living your childhood
Harold you know whenever you're standing
still in a department store do people
actually look at your clothes and like
where's the what's the price on this
yeah what's the price I think you're a
mannequin cuz you are you're a mannequin
you got RZ it's very aiish of me very AI
shove me all right let's look at this
clip now I have a machine
[Music]
gun all right so uh die hard making USA
Today that still exists yeah yeah list
of the best Christmas flicks the top 10
include Scrooge elf National Lampoons
Christmas vacation and Dana you'll be
happy to hear uh Love Actually is
actually on the list on the list it's
the worst movie ever made I still enjoy
it I'm still mad that that guy bought
the necklace for the office girl and
broke Emma's heart that was terrible no
I I like that movie um I like a lot of
the Christmas the newer like Country
Christmas songs those are good uh we
don't care okay you know um I don't know
what else to
say it's been years we've talked about
Love Actually but you know what uh judge
why do Christmas movies have to be only
in Christmas why can't you watch them
year around because somehow they don't
feel right I it doesn't feel right
watching Home Alone in July you know
when it's 90 degrees and you're on your
way to the beach it just doesn't make
sense but I got to tell you I have never
seen Love Actually good for you I I'm
not I mean I like the you know there's
not a lot of like shoot them up crime
Christmas shows though yeah there is we
just saw it with one yeah that's a good
one and I always thought the Godfather
when they're in front of best in company
you know that's a great Christmas movie
because it's you can watch it with your
family everybody sits around they're
eating a lot of food Good Fellas great
Christmas movie I think it is remember
they're making a meal where's that was
that for Christmas or I can't remember
and he was trying to get the drugs that
was that was the holiday time that
Christmas time Harold you were saying in
the Green Room not a lot of good adult
Christmas
films and I was like shocked I didn't
know what you meant but you mean movies
for adults and not for kids perhaps I
was saying adult and then said Christmas
and then see my favorite Christmas movie
is Trading Places oh very good Trading
Places it's it's a great people forget
it it's a Philly movie uh it it has it's
it's around Christmas time and one of
the great great lines is when Eddie
Murphy is outside of that club The
Heritage Club so with liberty and
justice for all members only what the
what the blackard reads but I love that
movie and my wife is a big National
Lampoon Christmas Vacation have that
running a lot do you have a favorite
Christmas film I Like Home Alone was
that not on the list yeah it was it was
on the list I can't see too much eggnog
last night yeah there you go all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else